OK.
Well, I like to lay in
the hammock in the summer.
And this is our version
of that hammock.
So we're having one rope,
or perhaps two ropes,
hanging between two trees here.
And they span an angle
theta on each side here.
And we want to know what
is the tension in this rope
at the midpoint and
here, right where
it is attached to the tree.
And here we already have
the free-body diagram.
I just drew this
piece of the rope here
that's hanging on
this tree here.
And we made an imaginary cut.
We just cut it in
the middle, which
means gravity is
obviously acting on it.
It's hanging through.
But it does so with m/2
here for our half rope.
We know that there is a tension
here at the midpoint, Tmid.
And up here, we have a
tension at that end point
that goes under this angle here.
I just use an ordinary
Cartesian coordinate system
with the i-hat direction going
in the x direction and j-hat
going in the y direction.
So all we need to do is we need
to apply Newton's second law
and do an F equals ma
analysis to figure out
what these tensions are.
So let's apply
Newton's second law,
the F equals ma
analysis, to figure out
what the tensions
are at the midpoint
and at the end over there.
So we have F equals ma.
And we'll have to very carefully
separate the components here.
Let's start with i-hat.
We have Tmid minus
Tend, but of course we
have only the
projection of Tend,
so this is Tend sine theta.
And since this rope
is just hanging there,
the acceleration is 0.
In the j-hat direction, we have
minus m/2 g and then plus Tend.
And here we have the cos theta
component, and that is also 0.
So we see from here
pretty much immediately
that Tend equals m/2
g over cos theta.
And we can stick this one
here into the i-hat equation.
So we'll get Tmid equals
m/2 cos theta g sine theta.
And that's nothing else but
mg/2 over 2 tangent theta.